derrière cette porte jean piat se
prépare à jouer domino pour la
télévision
au delà de l'écran nous sommes allé le
retrouver chez lui
derrière les invalides jean piat comment
devient même temps ceux qui étaient avec
lui française en ce qui me concerne le
par hasard à presque vois ça et bien
parce que j'ai commencé à faire du
théâtre
en 1944 il y avait un temps déjà et que
rien ou destinés au départ la colonie
française
j'avais été un spectateur assez peu
assidu de la comédie française
j'ai eu entre conservatoire bien sûr
mais je pensais aux dires de boulevard
et j'ai commencé par jouer au théâtre
grammont puis au théâtre saint-georges
et je n'ai rien fait pendant quelques
mois fin mais j'ai eu des difficultés
comme on n'a toujours pas dans des buts
et puis ensuite chez entre autres en
route à deux français sur audition car
pendant ces années là j'étais au
conservatoire mais j'avais été exclu du
conservatoire sur pour raisons
disciplinaires
rithy panh lève sort s'est lui aussi
jeté dressage mais manque d'assiduité
aux cours alors jamais été exclue
j'avais eu des concours assez médiocres
ou bien le dire
des concours de trimestriels par les
concours de sortie parce que concours
sortie je n'ai jamais pu y participer
et puis
j'avais quand même gardé des amitiés
suffisante est suffisamment solide au
théâtre français pour
être demandée sur audition et j'ai passé
l'audition et ça a marché et je vais
écouter plusieurs et 812 mais vous êtes
vraiment le type de l'exemple qu'on ne
doit pas donner aux enfants surtout
d'ailleurs tous les acteurs sont un peu
comme ça oui bien sûr il s'empresse
toujours de dire qu'ils ont ratée de
leurs écoles leurs études parce que pas
toujours aux aguets
l'essentiel c'est que vous n'ayez pas
rater votre carrière enfin ça je ne sais
pas léon nouvelle mais elle n'est que
commence pour l'instant oui mais dont
vous êtes maintenant sociétaires ce qui
est un titre candidats difficile à
obtenir non oui et non vous savez je
crois que le deux tiers français c'est
une c'est un théâtre exceptionnel
et quand les choses marchent tout va
très bien et on devient sociétaire très
rapidement maintenant
si on n'est pas fait pour ce théâtre là
essayer ce théâtre là n'est pas fait
pour vous il faut pas y rester bon
écoutez maintenant parlons un petit peu
de cyrano quand on vous a proposé le
rôle de cyrano
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé alors
j'étais vraiment très content parce que
j'avais eu quelques contacts déjà avec
le rôle quand un pire duclavé josiane
français y ait une bonne dizaine
d'années je crois et il remettait la
pièce en scène c'était une mise en scène
de lui avait fait la mise en scène de la
pièce 1,38 et y rejouer le rôle à ce
moment l'audi a2 français et j'avais eu
la joie de participer aux répétitions en
jouant un cadet le 1er 2e ou 3e je ne
sais plus et en même temps de tenir un
peu sa place pour les répétitions
d'ensemble et à ce moment-là à vis de
manger je peux pas vous que j'avais
découvert le rôle mais enfin je vais
découvrir le l'appétit du roule en tout
cas eu la joie de pouvoir le jouer et
d'ailleurs et c'est pas si duke se
sentent aimés il m'avait parlé un petit
peu dur ou la fin de la façon de le
prendre de le concevoir et 7 ce petit
travail à ce moment là m'a été utile
10 12 ou 15 ans plus tard il avait
pressenti un successeur oui je j'ose le
croire oui qu'est ce que vous pensez de
la pièce en soit la pièce asira là où
les personnages pro c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre tout simplement c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre eux qu'on doit placer dans
son époque dans son style c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre de générosité d'écriture
et de construction et
et c'est une pièce admirablement en fait
parce que rostand connaissait son métier
comme beaucoup d'auteurs et on ne
s'était pas au cloud avant cette époque
là il suffit simplement de se référer
aux indications scéniques
tout est inscrit d'ailleurs charon qui a
mis la pièce en scène cette fois-ci le
sait très bien et jacques dupont qui a
fait les décors ils se sont référés aux
indications de rostand ci concernaient
des choeurs les décors sont complètement
décrit à chaque acte quant aux
indications scéniques
elles sont très nombreuses de la part de
rostand et mêmes des indications
psychologique
alors ce qui concerne cyrano et les
autres personnages ça prouve qu'en tout
cas même si on lui conteste le talent
les gens se ruent au spectacle 110 ans
plus tard et ça prouve en tout cas que
les conseils ou les indications
scéniques qu'il donne sont à suivre
puisque la présentation actuelle en fait
foi
mais je crois que vous me citiez toute
allure d'ailleurs hameau de critiques
que je trouve excellent sur une espèce
de définition ikea peut plaire oui dix
ans d'ailleurs que le théâtre populaire
et peut-être ou sans doute le théâtre le
public se rue ce qui est assez évident
en ce qui concerne oui c'est ce
qu'ignore d'ailleurs trop de critiques
en général non là je veux dire que cette
fois ci on a été extrêmement gâté qu'est
ce que la presse est unanimement
favorables et par l oise ont dégoté un
petit écart n'est pas très grave
tant du côté physique du personnage la
transformation est importante
oui si tant est qu'un et transforma
visage au point où on le dit je crois
que la transformation physique est
importante aux mains quand on a
quelquefois dit très gentiment que
j'étais trop trop beau physiquement pour
jouer cyrano je ne le crois pas du tout
pour beaucoup de raisons parce que
d'abord je crois qu'un héros est
toujours beau parce qu'il est beau par
l'expression par les sentiments qui
l'animent et que
cyrano et le plus béraud le héros issime
si je puis dire des héros du répertoire
français donc il est encore plus beau
que les autres et il a évidemment cette
déformation physique il accuse lui même
cette déformation physique mais pour
employer les mots de notre époque c'est
un complexe qui là et je crois que c'est
autre chose
seulement il se trouve que roxanne est
amoureuse d'un autre homme et puis c'est
tout c'est ce qui fait le problème de la
pièce oui dans le fond le côté laideur
disons un mot de cyrano c'est lui même
qui ressent sa laideur mais est elle oui
elle existe bien sûr il y la 1ere di
cule grotesque et cetera mais le break
dès le premier inclut 10 m'enfin quoi
cette petite qui vient de te servira à
boire et à manger tu as regardé d'un
oeil charmant et n'était pas et du tout
impressionnée par talent et leur
physique
le bret son meilleur ami de lui dit
c'est pour le conforter pour le
réconforter ses son amitié qui lui
souffle cette réplique parce que il sent
le drame intérieur de cet homme mais
c'est donc un drap matériaux qui
extérieurement évidemment est visible
parce qu il n est grotesque mais pas les
jean pierre olié autre chose et que je
vous écoute attentivement et vous nous
donner à tous envie d'aller mieux
connaître ce personnage grâce à vous je
sais que je ne suis pas seul parce que
c'est très difficile d'avoir des places
au théâtre français écoutez je ne faut
surtout pas des coureurs je ferai un
effort je me le break bonheur général à
nos questions et gérez vous voir bientôt
[Musique]